mark Terrence Jones is proud to be game
in fact he's an organizer of hamburg's
gay pride parade in the past he had
difficulty reconciling his sexuality
with his Catholic faith so the Pope's
words meant a lot to him is specified
when I first heard it I couldn't believe
it I had to read it over again and watch
it again on TV I was surprised that he
did it the way he did maybe World Youth
Day inspired him a bit on the return
flight from Rio the Pope fielded
reporters questions and said something
no one was expecting to notice when a
gay if someone is gay and seeks the Lord
with Good Will who am I to judge it's
not clear how much acceptance from the
church the Pope statement will mean
liberal auxiliary bishop and Jochen
yashka in hamburg says it was an overdue
signum he hopes for an end to
discrimination was given was extra
dimension homosexual people exist
they're God's children and he loves them
like he does everyone else it's not our
place to judge them we have a history
that includes a lot of discrimination
and it's important that we overcome it
Superman Vishnu schist the pontiff
statement seemed to herald a new tone of
acceptance bought the Pope added that in
the church's eyes homosexual acts remain
a sin